>> ♪ ♪
>> Tucker: WELCOME TO "TUCKER
CARLSON TONIGHT" "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
WE HAVE SEEN A LOT OF CHANGE IN
THE 2 YEARS TRUMP HAS BEEN
PRESIDENT.
THE AMERICAN MEDIA HAS CHANGED
FOREVER.
THESE ORGANIZATIONS THAT SEEMED
LIKE A BIG DEAL 5 YEARS AGO ARE
EXTINCT AND SOME FORGOTTEN.
THOSE THAT REMAIN DEGRADED
THEMSELVES BEYOND RECOGNITION
LIKE THE NEW YORKER OR THEY HAVE
BEEN PURCHASED TO CONDUCT
LOBBYING FOR AMAZON.COM LIKE THE
"WASHINGTON POST."
NOT SO LONG AGO AMERICA HAD
PRESTIGE MEDIA OUTLETS.
HARVARD GRADUATES WENT TO WORK
FOR NEWSWEEK.
NOT ANYMORE.
TEEN VOGUE HAS A NEWS DIVISION
AND SO DOES A BLOG CALLED BUZZ
FEED.
IF YOU ARE AN AFFLUENT SINGLE
PERSON WHO LIKES CATS, THEN YOU
KNOW AND LOVE BUZZ FEED.
WHEN A BUZZ FEED HEADLINE
COMMANDS YOU TO STOP EVERYTHING
AND WATCH THIS, YOU DO.
YOU STOP EVERYTHING AND YOU
WATCH THAT CAT.
WHEN BUZZ FEED OFFERS A
TRADEMARK CAT QUIZ, YOU TAKE THE
QUIZ.
WHAT KIND OF PURS-ANALITY DOES
YOUR CAT HAVE?
TAKE THIS QUIZ.
MEOW!
YOU THINK YOU KNOW A LOT ABOUT
CATS.
BUZZ FEED KNOWS MORE.
ALL ON QUESTIONS FELINE BUZZ
FEED IS THE FINAL AUTHORITY.
WHAT HAPPENS WHEN BUZZ FEED
TRIES TO DO REAL NEWS.
IN 2017 WE FOUND OUT.
RELEASING THE TRUMP DOSSIER, IT
WAS UNVERIFIED GOSSIP FINANCED
BY THE DNC BY PRESIDENT-ELECT
TRUMP.
MANY OTHER NEWS OUTLETS SAW THE
DOSSIER BUT PASSED ON IT.
BUT NOT BUZZ FEED.
THEY THOUGHT IT WAS PURR-FECT SO
THEY RAN IT.
2 YEARS AGO LATER THE BUZZ FEED
DOSSIER DEFINES THE ENTIRE TRUMP
RUSSIAN COLLUSION CONSPIRACY
TALE.
A LOT OF DOSSIER IS UNTRUE.
FOR EXAMPLE, ONE KEY CLAIM IN
THE DOSSIER THAT BUZZ FEED RAN
WAS THAT THE TRUMP ATTORNEY
MICHAEL COHEN HELD SECRET
MEETINGS WITH RUSSIAN AGENTS IN
PRAGUE.
THEY NEVER OFFERED ANY EVIDENCE
AND LAST WEEK MICHAEL COHEN
HIMSELF CONFIRMED IT NEVER
HAPPENED.
>> HAVE YOU EVER BEEN TO PRAGUE?
>> NEVER HAVE.
NEVER BEEN TO THE CZECH
REPUBLIC.
>> Tucker: THAT SEEMS LIKE A BIG
DEVELOPMENT.
2 YEARS AGO BUZZ FEED TOLD US
THAT MICHAEL COHEN HELD A SECRET
MEETING WITH RUSSIAN SPIES IN
PRAGUE.
WE HAVE BEEN HEARING THAT ABOUT
EVER SINCE IN CONGRESS AND ON
CABLE NEWS.
HE HALTED THE NORMAL WORKINGS OF
GOVERNMENT BECAUSE OF THAT
MEETING.
NOW IT TURNS OUT IT NEVER TOOK
PLACE.
IT'S NOT A SMALL THING TO LEARN
FROM MICHAEL COHEN.
HOW DID BUZZ FEED COVER THIS
LATEST STUNNING DEVELOPMENT?
THEY DIDN'T COVER IT.
THEY IGNORED IT.
BUZZ FEED FLOATED A STORY ABOUT
21 LIFE CHANGING THINGS YOU CAN
MAKE IN A WAFFLE MAKER.
THERE WAS NOTHING ABOUT THE
NON-EXISTENT MICHAEL COHEN
RUSSIAN SPY MEETING IN
PRACTICING.
-- PRAGUE.
A LOT OF PEOPLE IN THE MEDIA
ONLY READ BUZZ FEED AND NOT JUST
FOR CAT COVERAGE.
BUZZ FEED PUBLISHED A STORY WITH
THIS SENTENCE.
PRESIDENT TRUMP DIRECTED HIS
LONG TIME ATTORNEY MICHAEL COHEN
TO LIE TO CONGRESS ABOUT
BUILDING A TRUMP TOWER IN
MOSCOW.
BUZZ FEED DID NOT SHOW THAT WAS
TRUE.
IT DIDN'T MATTER.
THE CAT LOVERS ON CABLE NEWS
WENT CRAZY.
>> IT WOULD BE A BOMBSHELL.
>> THE LATEST REPORT.
>> A BOMBSHELL REPORT.
>> FROM BUZZ FEED.
>> IF THIS IS TRUE.
>> THE BOMBSHELL REPORT.
>> Tucker: IT WAS REALLY A
BOMBSHELL.
SOMETIMES IT WAS.
THE CLAIM WAS DIRECTING SOMEONE
TO LIE UNDER OATH IS A FELONY.
THIS BEEN TRUE THE TRUMP
PRESIDENCY WOULD HAVE ENDED FOR
A LEGITIMATE REASON.
BUT IT WAS NOT TRUE.
IT WAS LIKE THE CLAIM THAT CAT
SUCKS BREATH FROM BABY OR A
BLACK CAT BRINGS BAD LUCK.
THE MUELLER INVESTIGATION ITSELF
BAD DOWN BUZZ FEED'S STORY AFTER
THIS CAME OUT.
BUZZ FEED NEVER RETRACTED THE
PIECE.
THE SITE PRETENDED THAT NOTHING
HAPPENED.
YOU CAN YELL AT A CAT BUT CAN'T
MAKE IT PAY ATTENTION.
THE KEY QUOTES FROM THE JANUARY
BUZZ FEED STORY.
TRUMP DIRECTED MICHAEL COHEN TO
LIE TO CONGRESS AND THE
PRESIDENT PERSONALLY INSTRUCTED
HIM TO LIE."
AND ONE AGAIN, THE FIRST EXAMPLE
OF TRUMP TELLING A SUBORDINANT
TO LIE ABOUT HIS OWN DEALINGS
WITH RUSSIA.
THAT'S THE CLAIM.
DEMOCRATIC MEMBERS OF CONGRESS
ASKED MICHAEL COHEN LAST WEEK
ABOUT THAT SPECIFIC CLAIM.
COHEN WAS UNDER OATH AT THE
TIME.
A DECLARED ENEMY OF DONALD
TRUMP.
NOT SOMEONE WHO HAD ANY REASON
TO LIE.
HERE'S HOW HE RESPONDED.
>> MR. TRUMP DID NOT TELL ME TO
LIE TO CONGRESS.
THAT'S NOT HOW HE OPERATES.
>> Tucker: OKAY.
MAKE SURE WE HAVE THIS CLEAR.
TRUMP DIRECTED MICHAEL COHEN TO
LIE.
HE PERSONALLY INSTRUCTED HIM TO
HE EXPLICITLY TOLD HIM.
THOSE ARE THE CLAIMS FROM BUZZ
FEED.
DID MICHAEL COHEN REALLY DO
THAT?
HERE'S HIS ACT AGAIN.
>> DID THE PRESIDENT IN ANY WAY
COACH YOU IN TERMS OF HOW TO
RESPOND TO QUESTIONS OR THE
CONTENTS OF YOUR TESTIMONY
BEFORE A HOUSE COMMITTEE?
>> AGAIN IT'S DIFFICULT TO
ANSWER.
HE DOESN'T TELL YOU WHAT HE
WANTS.
WHAT HE DOES, AGAIN, MICHAEL,
THERE IS NO RUSSIA.
THERE IS NO COLLUSION.
THERE IS NO INTERFERENCE.
I KNOW WHAT HE MEANS BECAUSE I
HAVE BEEN AROUND HIM FOR SO
LONG.
IF YOU ARE ASKING ME WHETHER OR
NOT THAT'S THE MESSAGE ON POINT,
THAT'S THE PARTY LINE THAT HE
CREATED THAT SO MANY OTHERS ARE
NOW TOUTING, YES, THAT'S THE
MESSAGE HE WANTED TO REINFORCE.
>> Tucker: THAT'S THE MESSAGE.
MICHAEL COHEN SAID THAT TRUMP
CLAIMED THERE WAS NO RUSSIAN
COLLUSION AND NO INTERFERENCE IN
THE 2016 PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION.
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT TRUMP HAS
BEEN TELLING THE WORLD FOR 2
YEARS.
EVERY DAY IN A LOUD VOICE TO
ANYONE WHO WILL LISTEN.